.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Que révèle le fleuve Saint-
Laurent?
- OK, nous autres, on est prêts.
- OK, c'est beau, on va y aller.
♪ ♪ ♪
- De sa naissance
à la sortie du lac Ontario,
jusqu' s son estuaire
dans la région de Québec,
ses eaux sont sous la loupe
d'un groupe de chercheurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est la journée la plus chargée
à bord du navire Lampsilis.
Le laboratoi f flottant
s'arrêtera sur dix points
d'échantillonnage.
On récoltera avec cette
bouteille les eaux les plus
contaminées du Saint-Laurent.
- Renaud, regarde le visuel.
Vois-tu là, là, leououillon
qu'il y a là? Ah oui, oui,
on se recule pour essayer
de dériver directement à côté.
- Les dernières missions
du Lampsilis ont révélé
la présence d'importantes
concentrations de coliformes
fécaux sur la rive nord
du fleuve allant de Montréal
au lac Saint-Pierre.
L'équi d du professeur
François Guillemette trace
l'origine des colonies
d'E. coli. Souvent responsable
de la fermeture des plages,
cette bactérie vit dans
les intestins des humains
et des animaux à sang chaud.
FRANÇOIS GUILLEMETTE, prof.,
sciences environnem., UQTR
- On a commencé à s'intéresserà,
à étudier la génétique
des fameuses bactéries
et de voir avec elle,
est-ce qu'on peut retracer
maintenant cette bactérie-l
à un humain, un porc, une vache,
par exemple, à une poule,
un oiseau?
- Ses résultats préliminaires
sont surprenants. Le rôle
des municipalités dans
la contamination bactériologique
du fleuve pourrait être
plus important qu'anticipé.
- On pensait, comme beaucoup
de gens, par exemple,
que certains tributaires
pouvaient être... amener des
charges importantes de sources
plutôt agricoles, par exemple,
bovines ou porcines.
Il y a quelques tributaires
de la rive sud où on a retrouvé
certaines sources bovines,
mais dans le fleuve en tant
que tel, pour l'instant,
c'est principaleme
une source humaine.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'une des principales sources
d'E. coli : les rejets d'eaux
usées de la ville de Montréal.
C'est ici, entre Varennes
et l'île aux Vaches, que les
conduites déversent bactéries
et résidus pharmaceutiques.
- On est à environ un million
de compte de coliformes fécaux
par 100 ml d'eau filtrée, qui
est une mesure standardisée.
Donc, pour rappel, la baignade
est environ à 200, et 1000
pour les activités de contact
indirect, canotage, pêche, etc.
Donc, on est vraiment, vraiment
au-dessus des normes,
on s'entend, là. Et ça restera
comme ça, très concentré,
poes prochaines stations
qu'on va faire ce matin.
Et on sera quelque part
entre 2000 à 3000 dans
le lac Saint-Pierre plus loin.
- Perché à l'antnt du navire,
Matthew Chapman scrute
un archipel dans les environs
de Varennes.
MATTHEW CHAPMAN, militant et
trésorier, Coalition Climat Mtl
- Je suis intéressé surtout
à cause du fait que je suis
riverain... du Saint-Laurent.
- Dans un souci de partage
des connaissances scientifiques,
l'équipage l'a invité à bord
du Lampsilis. Le militant
MATTHEW CHAPMAN, militant et
trésorier,oaoalition Climat Mtl
- Je suis intéressé surtout
à cause du fait que je suis
riverain... du Saint-Laurent.
- Dans un souci de partage
des connaissances scientiqiques,
l'équipage l'a invité à bord
du Lampsilis. Le militant
écologiste s'est porté acquéreur
de l'île à la Truie, en 2020,
une île en plein coeur
de l'effluent de Montréal.
- J'aimerais même me baigner,
voir mes enfants se baigner.
Pas possible à l'heu a actuelle
à cause de la pollution
dans l'eau.
- La Ville de Montréal
n'est pas la seule responsable
des concentrations importantes
de coliformes fécaux. En aval,
d'autres rivières sous pression
contaminent le fleuve.
- On a déjà une charge
importante là, puis
toutes les municipalités
en plus, les petits tributaires
qui vont couler au nord du lac
Saint-Pierre vont en rajouter.
Ça va se poursuivre maintenant
jusqu'à Trois-Rivières comme ça.
Là, il reste à savoir, c'est qui
qui en met plus ou moins.
Ça, c'est une autre question.
Mais, pour l'instant, on voit
très bienu'u'il y a une tendance
forte à avoir des contaminations
en rive, qui n'ont rien à voir
avec Montréal.
- D'importants efforts devront
être consentis pour rejeter
des eaux plus propres. Montréal,
elle, planche sur une unité
de désinfection, dont la mise
en service est prévue pour 2025.
- J'aimerais voir que les usines
de traitenent de l'eau sont
à la hauteur du défi.
Ça veut dire traiter l'eau
comme il faut avant de
la déverser dans les cours d'eau
autour de nous.
- Comment est-ce qu'on doit,
par exemple, mettre des usines
de traitement des eaux usées
à jour? Ça, on sait que c'est
un gros enjeu, les surverses
aussi, où est-ce qu'il y
des entrées d'eau trop
importantes, puis la capacité
de traiter cette eau-là
n'espapas assez suffisante
durant les épisodes de forts
événements de pluie.
Est-ce qu'on doit, maintenant,
penser à dire que c'est là
que l'argent doit aller
pour mettre les usines à jour?
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les observations du Lampsilis
dévoilent l'ampleur du chantier
qu